今月は外れ雪をです
すいませんさっき東京から入ってきて google 時間がありませんでしたすい
ませんですよねなんか最近毎日動画出せてないんですけど年からいろんな理由があり
まして
まあ今日に関して本当に東京に出たからちょっと時間がなかったというだけなんです
けどまぁちょっと畑が増えるとかも色々あったりなんかこうしなきゃいけねー事が増え
たりいろんなことがあってちょっとために道が出せないことがあるんですけども
してください僕は全然元気なお気になさらず抜けず分やってられないんで去らないで
下さいません
そういうわけで前回悪口つのコーナーやったんですけどそうなると普通の質問コーナー
も結構やってないんだっていうことで
質問募集することにしましたーー
でありがてたのいつ何時はどう映ったようで今 is 何時でもそのやっぱり質問
コーナーまだまだっていうことがたくさん言われるんで味でも監査
肇社長遊ばずコーナーみたいになってるんですけどもういいですよ全然おっ構えあり
ませんどんどん老けコメント書いちゃってください何度いい子で2分けで僕に対する
質問リクエスト悪口なんかもう何でもいいねこの動画のコメント欄に書いて
ください
嘘ですね同課は最後まで見るとわかんないこと多いからなぁ今コメントに書いてつ
上はちょっと珍しくですねツイッターの方で募集しようと思っております何から
youtube のコメントたまになんか消えたりするんですよあのー
今まで隠してたけど色まで覚醒なんですけど実はこのコメントを聞いたりするんですよ
ね
ほんと申し訳ないと思ってると twitter だったら消えないんであの
ツイッターで僕に対する何か質問とリクエスト言いたいことはる月文句動画飲んでた
動画のネタ動画もネタあったらどんどん書いてくださいまし@肇社長に送るんじゃなく
て
撥水各売っちゃった空
[音楽]
発信卓数3節をフライパン食べたりしましょうハッシュタグ始めたとフライパン食べ
たらパッと見知らないとこれを見ると弾みさそれぐらいから食べたんじゃに
ねーってビビると思うんで
レヴィだせたいだけですはいぜひでコメントダイン
ちょっと twitter なんでねあ目の前の動画も行ったんですけど実は隣が弾み
アミューズメントパークなんですよ
ん
goo
[音楽]
ん
dee
うふっさー迷惑廃城令で久しぶりの質問コーナーでございますかコツいってわけで
ツイッターとはまずは何年ぶりかわかんないんですけど結局絶対て見やすいですよね皆
さんの質問を待つしておりますや俺は失点では youtube のコメント欄も
面白いんですけど
twitter 面白いということを吹く知ってるんで何でもいいので思いの丈を変え
てください頑張って拾いまくりますので時は10月7日南
で10月の15日まで1週間くらい待ってみます10月の15日までツイッターでお
待ちしております
[音楽]
いやーこれ
誰かいる
誰
聞こえてないわい
だれがー
これ
ゴルガー
聞こえてるなぁ
4型ああ
あとねそっち行くわー
はやーい
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
砺波ああいう都会ができるって凄いよねっ
うっさ